The value added to theater and you know,
I know this is a debate that has gone on
for millions of years and hopefully
we'll still go over a of years,
is that there is no experience like it.
It's live your live,
they're live,
they're feeding off you,
your feeding off them,
you know,
and an audience senses that and that's,
that is an added value and I don't
really care how technology pushes us
forward.
There's never going to be anything like
sitting in a theater with 100 or 1000
people around you laughing,
crying,
you know,
doing all those emotional things that,
that hopefully good theater will do for
you.
And my challenge and the challenge that
we have as an industry is getting people
to recognize that and into,
you know,
the theater and you know,
the complaint that I hear I hear to the
most about theater specifically the
price and the accessibility and the
accessibility.
I'm going to go backwards.
The accessibility is something as an
industry,
I think actually technology and the
theater world can marry more.
There are people out there that don't
know how to get tickets,
so they think that getting tickets are
complicated.
They don't understand.
You can go online now and,
and I think,
you know,
the technology in that case has helped
the theater industry tremendously.
I mean there was a day,
and I'm not that old,
but there was a day that I remember the
only way you could get a theater ticket
was to go to the box office know and,
and now it's,
it's,
we've expanded that.
So it is,
it is amazing.
To me the idea of it being too expensive
is something that you know,
is a challenge to the industry to and to
that I always say my job is to let
people know there are many ways and many
different prices of seeing shows.
There's the tk ats booth,
there's a,
you know,
there's,
there's direct mail,
there's email blasts.
We're starting to use that technology.
And so I think those two obstacles when
you add it together and the added value
is to,
to get the world on the same.
There's no experience like live theater
that they can't be live streaming hd
filming.
Um,
even the audience that is listening to
this conversation right now,
it would be,
it's not at all like if we were sitting
in a room live and that's the,
the excitement of live theater.
We find that the younger generation,
unless they have come,
been brought to the theater,
don't get it.
It seems like their grandmothers form of
entertainment.
Um,
and you know,
to that personally,
I have been a,
and I,
most of my career have been a big
advocate of getting a school children
into the theater and whether that is a
Wednesday matinee where you donate
tickets or a,
we have a program right now with the
city school system that we choose,
you know,
one school every Wednesday matinee.
Um,
and they get 100 tickets.
Some of the schools do it on merit,
some do it on financial need.
You know,
each school is a little bit different.
But I find,
and this is one of the greatest joys
that I have as a producer,
is watching those kids watch a show.
Many of them for the very first time and
you can tell which ones are hooked,
you can tell because again,
they're sensing without any explanation
there watching someone live.
I remember once when I was producing a
musical called jellies,
last jam and the Lake Gregory hines play
Jelly Roll Morton and we took every
Wednesday matinee.
They were a hundred inner school in city
school.
Kids that got to see the show and one
Wednesday matinee.
A couple of kids didn't realize,
you know,
they saw it was live but they didn't
know the decorum of theater and they
were screaming out.
Gregory Gregory.
Yeah,
my man,
you know,
and they were just so excited and he
kind of stopped the show and he just
very calmly said,
you know,
we are so glad you are here is so cool,
but you know,
what's not cool?
I'm trying to,
you know,
so I'll tell you what man,
why don't you like,
let,
let's do the show.
That's how this works.
And then you guys come back stage and we
can wrap and these kids will like over
the moon.
And it wasn't because they were,
you know,
Ruda some,
but they will hooked.
Man.
I was watching those kids,
they were so hooked onto live theater.
And I thought this is cool.
They had just never experienced that
before.
You know,
every,
every form,
event,
attendance,
these kids that had up to this point in
their life was a movie,
was a TV,
was a video,
was something they had never gone and
had that,
oh my God,
there's a person up there.
And they happen to know the person was
A.
Yeah,
I love when that happens.
And that's a big,
huge added value.
When I was a kid,
they were saying the great white way is
dead.
No,
they were calling other fabulous
invalid.
I don't believe it ever will die because
of that.
A feeling that,
that idea that you can't get it anywhere
else.
And I think the younger generation,
they may be slower to get there.
But um,
you know,
if we do our job right,
we'll get them,
you know,
there,
there are those kind of hip cool shows
where it's cool to go and they go,
wow,
this isn't so bad.
And you know.
Yeah.
So you kinda got them.